[Music]
hello everyone welcome to Fandango indie
movie guide I'm Alicia and can you
believe that it is almost the end of
2016 where did this year go don't worry
there's still plenty of little gems for
you to enjoy at the theaters and at home
as we ramp up towards the end of the
year let's start with one that has
awards watch all over it particularly
for the performances actually also for
the director and the screenplay as well
it's called fences and this is an
adaptation of the Pulitzer Prize winning
play by August Wilson by the same name
and it stars genteel Washington and
Viola Davis they're two people living in
1950s Philadelphia it's very much a look
at race relations and also a look at how
one man is struggling with his anger at
the world which spills out towards his
family how come you never liked me what
law is there say I got to like you a man
is supposed to take care of his family
you live in my house for your belly with
my food put your behind on my bed
because you're my son now don't you go
through life worrying about whether
somebody like you or not you best be
making sure they're doing right by you
as I said this is really all about the
performances you can definitely tell
that you're watching a play it feels
like you're watching a play but that
doesn't detract from the movie at all
because it's just such a treat to see
brilliant actors at work you've got
Denzel Washington who always is powerful
but here he shows how he's so able to
turn on a dime between being very
charming to being extremely terrifying
and angry
Viola Davis always incredible but here
she is like an emotional gut
for me to admit that I've been standing
in the same place for 18 years with you
I got a life there's a Washington also
directed fences and I thought he did a
great job of adapting the play so many
character moments that are great and so
many fantastic monologues to so see
fences in theaters when you can again
its opening very limited so far but then
it'll be rolling out and expanding
throughout the next couple of weeks some
people build fences to keep people out
and other people build fences to keep
people in now to another film that has
Awards watch on it for Best Foreign Film
it's Neruda directed by Pablo Laraine
the same director as behind Jackie he's
incredible and this is about the Nobel
prize-winning poet Pablo Neruda and the
search for him when he became a fugitive
in his own country thanks to being a
communist tomas important to el mundo
senator Manar osakawa Eppolito we put
literacy beyond kilometer literacy
tapasya
Gael Garcia Bernal was in Pablo
Lorraine's
other film know from 2012 and here he
plays a police officer who's trying to
track down Pablo Neruda who is played by
Chilean actor Luis Necco now much like
Jackie it's kind of a blurred line
between what is fact and what is fiction
here it's a mixture of historical and
lyrical not so much a biopic but also
kind of a really unique buy pick at the
same time it's very much like an
experience at the theater that makes
them to John it's like a homicidal
pollution on
you know they'd be that we would have
done us in your vision also tell you to
see see see talk table Lorraine he is a
director to watch reminds me a little
bit of Aronofsky but again he has its
own unique perspective going on I highly
recommend checking out Neruda it's out
in some theaters this weekend but it
will be out in more in the future and
also on video on demand
what good do we have enough ambition I
also want to put on your radar
another little movie that came out just
over a week ago in limited theaters and
on video on-demand definitely worth
watching
it's called always shine directed by
Sophia to Cal and it's a psychological
thriller about jealousy between friends
excuse me I've seen you ins and
something we're on TV right this is this
is my friend Emma she's she's also an
actress
have I seen you in anything no I would
be surprised
Mackenzie Davis and Caitlin Fitzgerald
play two friends who are both actors and
at the start of the film Caitlin's
character is much more successful than
Mackenzie's character and that causes a
lot of jealousy plus their friendship
was already beginning to fray and it all
spills over into some passive aggressive
madness when they go away for a weekend
in big surf what is it just a really
dumb horror movie you have to seek your
close-up it's like the tenth time in two
years
looks like before the film is quite
experimental it reminds me a lot of
David Lynch's movies particularly mahal
and drive and a lot of people have
compared it to Ingmar Bergman's persona
which I can definitely see great sixties
film that one it has a lot to say about
women and there are multiple metal
layers going on
so definitely seek out always shine on
video on demand right now
we all be over soon enough anyway that's
right
[Music]
to recap in series if you can find
fences with those brilliant performances
or find Neruda with the experimental
tone and at home seek out always shine
for some truth about female friendships
that's it for this week's episode of
fandango indie movie guide as always
leave me a comment below I read every
single one to let me know which movies
you're looking forward to what you've
seen that you've loved what you're
really frustrated that you can't see
just yet and you can also chat to me
anytime on Twitter at Alicia Malone I'll
see you next week